it's not how you start it's how you
finish so time for this month's Doctor
Who list and this one is is gonna be
interesting because I'm gonna have to
spend a chunk of time explaining exactly
what it is I'm doing
I am ranking the exits of the primary
companions in the modern era now a
couple of things about how I'm deciding
to do this because some people are gonna
disagree with me was to what does or
doesn't count as an exit and companions
I first of all despite my own what I
consider to be a companion I'm only
dealing with the primary companions
people who the actors had their name in
the opening credits and not just for a
special so we're talking rose we're
talking Martha Donna Amy Rory bill
nardole Clara those are the people who
were dealing with here obviously we're
not dealing with the current companions
because none of them have left as yet so
those are the people we're dealing with
now exit of the show is not the same as
final appearance because many of these
characters had later appearances after
their actual formal exit so I'm talking
at which the circumstances of which the
character was written out of their role
as a primary companion that is what I'm
talking about
and in some cases some of these
characters are still actually going to
show off on this list more than once
Clara most primarily yeah I'll deal with
that when I get there so for how I chose
to consider these oh and there is okay
so there's one on here who like maybe
barely meets my criteria for main
companion but I'm still gonna count it
anyways but anyways I've got 13
these is what I've got so it starts the
bottom work her way up the bottom spot
should not come as a surprise to anyone
who's been around my channel before it's
Clara's exit in hell-bent because holy
crap this was awful and made all the
worse for the fact that it undid her her
very well-written and thematic and and
emotionally impactful death in face the
Raven yeah you should have know I'm
talking about the way characters leave
you should have known there were
spoilers here and no face the Raven
actually isn't gonna be on here because
as awesome as that was and as much as I
like it not just because like oh she
died didn't like or no it was a really
well-written death that a core occurred
and everyone involved knew she was
coming back later that same series so I
don't count that as an exit cuz it was
designed at the time to be temporary it
was never intended to continue on so
this the the hell-bent exit with the
doctor undoing what I get like I get
that he's torn up but like undoing a
thematic allah azza manned emotionally
devastating death and instead have her
sail off in her in her own version of
the TARDIS with her own companion why
why except the doctor doesn't remember
her like this that nothing about this
works
there's no catharsis to it there's no
proper tragedy to it
just because what is it happened he
doesn't remember Clara yeah but he
remembers that there was somebody he
doesn't remember her face so what is to
everything about it is soft it lacks
commitment because face the Raven if
they'd stuck with that that would have
been a commitment then we got this and
it sucks
so moving up from that we have number 12
now also I should be clear that bottom
one that's actually the only one I think
is flat-out bad from here it's just a
matter of preference
but moving up from one number 12 bill
Potts exiting in the dark
Falls this one I was actually surprised
I ended up putting this solo because I
really liked the doctor Falls and I
really like what happens to bill except
the thing that I realize is if I'm
talking about her proper exit from the
series it's not what happens to her in
world enough in time when she gets cyber
converted which is amazingly done that
entire thing and even as it carries over
into the doctor falls and you know the
doctor has to say to her you know I yes
he was telling the truth when he said he
could fix her but he was wrong and I
love that but ultimately the way she
exit isn't really tied to that because
they bring back Heather
kind of except it's the sentient fuel
but it's also kind of the girl she had a
crush on who kind of brings her back to
life sort of and again it's it's a
softening of what felt like a more
proper exit and you know I'm gonna boom
own the loss of the tragedy on this as
well as what happened on Clara I'm not
saying that because like I ate for the
tragic resolution I likes I'd like
positive stuff when I can get it when it
rings true and it doesn't just feel like
I can we get this a little happier there
which is what it feels a bit like with
Bill not nearly as jarring as the Clara
one from before but still not great
number eleven worried from angels in
Manhattan yeah I'm actually gonna deal
with Rory and Amy separately why is Rory
lower than Amy well because Amy gets a
heck of a lot more proper focus on her
exit there Rory does worry while he you
know he has his initial sort of thing
with Amy when they both decide to follow
that's actually quite nice his actual
legs is just and it had these stupid
thing there we go and he's and he's gone
and there and again there's nothing
wrong with a suddenness to it but his
exit serves more as an impact on Amy to
result in her exit his exit from the
show is more of a tool for us to get to
something that
is considered sadder Rory the tool it's
kind of a shame because I really like
Rory but he's not given full focus he's
and and while it may be fitting
ultimately that his exit is just a
service of Amy because ultimately his
life and the character like even
knowingly the characters are just in
service of Amy but I don't know it just
bums me out a little
next up number 10 nardole in the doctor
falls I'd like that like this is to me
is a nice amicable departure where he's
just just gets a little bit of scolding
in when the doctor tells him to leave me
is like I'm gonna but I'm not happy like
this I'm gonna name a town after you a
really lousy one I just love that that
animosity that's not like open hostility
but just like you frustrate the heck out
of me man that nardole has towards the
doctor and yet there's the affection
behind it it's a nice little goodbye and
nardole gets to go off and have whatever
he it is that he's gonna end up having
but it's it's low-key
and it feels right for a character like
Naruto who was you I do consider her
primary coming you know names in the
title and everything but was always very
secondary to bill so having a more
low-key exit but just getting a nice
little moment like that it's nice I like
it it's not showy so it's not higher but
I still like it all right next up Rose
in journey's end
so yes Rose is gonna show up on here
twice but here's where this one is so
with roses exit in journey's end this is
her return to her parallel world where
she gets to have the meta-crisis doctor
all to herself and again this is a
little bit of what I've talked about
before kind of undoing the tragedy of
her original exit which it's higher
we'll get to it but here it doesn't feel
as much undermining because it's not
doing it in as short a time span because
whereas what happened to bill like the
tragedy and then the redemption happens
you know at one episodes of the night
and Clara you know there was one episode
in between and then she's saved more or
less and that really does undermine it
because he didn't even have the chance
to sit with it and digest it Rose we had
the proper amount of time from her
original exit to when she came back and
then had to say goodbye again and it did
feel that given that there was that time
in between where it felt like we were
living with the weight of them not
getting to Barbara to say goodbye to
have them kind of have something closer
to that felt nice it felt earned in a
way that the things that went on with
Bill and Clara just didn't this is the
good version of undercutting the tragedy
number 8 Martha Jones in the last of
Time Lords this is gonna be her only
entry because her later appearances and
then like when she shows up at the end
of time part 2 it's really just the
camera established like and this is kind
of where she is now it doesn't feel like
a reiteration or proper ASA so this is
her only entry and I do like that she
makes the decision for herself I want to
be here I've enjoyed my time here but
this isn't good for me and I mean for
myself and to be the best version of me
that I'm gonna be I need to go and she
does and it's a real tribute to the
strength of Martha of who she is that
she gained the perspective of all that
and just went yeah I've I've had my fill
and and I and I like that for it it's
nice to have somebody voluntarily choose
to leave the TARDIS because the vast
majority of these are you know they some
something forces them off it's nice to
have someone actually choose to leave
she's the only one that's nice number
seven the one who is debatable in her
companion status but I'm sticking on
this list cuz it's my list and I can
River Song in the husbands of River Song
this episode I actually have fairly
mixed feelings about parts of it are
really cheesy but the ending and the
affection between her and Capaldi is so
genuine
and his just sense of and let's just be
together and her mix of joy and sadness
at knowing that this is it is just a
wonderful thing I really really do like
the two of them together and I'm kind of
sorry they didn't get to have more
stories together aside from this one but
this this works really well and the two
of them released they sell the heck out
of that scene out of that closing scene
at actor ilium and it's it's just good
stuff I mean that's the power of good
chemistry because the writing is decent
but it's the performances that totally
sell this number six Donna Noble the end
of time part two so this is Donna's
second exit and she gets one here
whereas Martha didn't do even though
it's in the same episode because Donna
is actually a bit more integrated into
this story whereas Martha we just get a
little note at the very end that's the
same thing that happens with Jack in
this whereas here it really does feel
like we're we're getting a reassurance
that she's going to be okay because
we'll get to her original exit from
things and a little bit um and also
again sort of the undercutting of the
tragedy but there is the space of time
because even though this is sort of
coming on the heels of series four we
had a year worth of specials from
journey's end
to here so like with Rose getting her
her less tragic second go at an exit
there was the time in-between to let the
weight of that tragedy sit with us for a
bit and so it doesn't feel like it's
just undercutting it and lessening the
punch so this has that going for it and
I mean part of this is just my Donna
bias which I totally copped to I won't
even I won't even pretend otherwise I
love Donna and knowing that Donna's
gonna be okay and maybe even happy I
kind of needed that so
top five Amy Pond Angels in Manhattan
yeah Rory got low lower because his
exit' was basically in service of making
this exit more impactful but this exit
is actually pretty dang impactful so her
seeing Rory gone and having to finally
like after having to have symbolically
repeatedly or in a short-term sense
choose between the doctor and Rory Amy
finally has to truly choose between them
finally true finality to this decision
and the weight of that on her and the
performance that we get from Karen
Gillan and the weight of that choice on
the doctor but also making what I'm
gonna say she made the right call that
was the call she should have made and we
get the little coda on it with the
little message left for the doctor
because he doesn't like to read the last
page of a book and she knew him well
enough to know that it's nice it's sweet
it's sad but just with enough sweetness
to know she made a hard decision but
ultimately also the right one number
four
Rose Tyler in doomsday huh that wall man
either side of that wall and from their
perspective it's just a wall but it is a
universe away and Rose pounding pounding
her fists on that wall desperate to get
back and the doctor just leaned his head
against it and just knowing that he
can't have her back and the music holy
cow the music
and they get their little goodbye moment
that gets cut off because sometimes even
when you think you have the time you
still don't and you have to live with
that this is really good like the first
proper tragedy of new who - in my
personal opinion like you could I
suppose some people could consider the
the ninth doctor's regeneration into ten
but I mean like the regeneration also is
always you know the the sadness of
losing the doctor before is always
tempered by while we get the new one now
and but this this feels properly tragic
and beautiful for number three this one
again someone whose status as a
companion possibly slightly more
debatable he didn't have his name in the
credits but he travelled and enough
back-to-back episodes that I'm gonna
count him and I was surprised at where I
put him and how high he landed but again
while I looked at these I'm like no I
love that Mickey in the age of steel'
now Mickey would ultimately come back in
journey's end but again much like the
return of Captain Jack and Sarah Jane
Smith in that he's just kind of there to
be part of the team and his going back
is just him going back to his status of
not being on the show this is his exit
and even though he shows up later in the
same season in doomsday this is the this
is the point at which he is making the
choice I'm done and everything building
up to this choice is perfect I take a
lot of issues with this two-parter
there's a lot I don't like about it but
Mickey is awesome finding his
grandmother in this other demand
and watching him choke up talking to her
and simultaneously you know coming to
terms cuz he's known it's not like he
suddenly realized he's known that the
doctor only put up with Mickey because
Rose was there and the doctor would
never have picked Mickey and he would
always pick Rose over him and Mickey
knew that but he comes to terms with
that here and realizes I don't actually
have a reason to be traveling with you
but I have a reason to stay here so I'm
gonna do that so I know I said Martha
was the only one when Martha is the only
actor named and the credits companion
who chose to leave but Mickey also chose
to leave and I'm I got to put this above
Martha's choosing to leave because it
felt I felt that it was more the natural
conclusion to the story
whereas Martha's Wow well earned didn't
feel as much of a yeah but for Mickey
yeah it does and I know people are gonna
be shouting at me because Mickey's on
here but some like Captain Jack isn't on
here at all cuz honestly I didn't even I
couldn't even figure out what to
consider his exit because he he really
does he's had like his final appearance
and he had little notes and his
appearances here and there but none of
them ever felt like designed to be a
sign off for him I feel like in some
ways were still waiting for that so he's
nowhere on this list which means we're
down to the last two one of them I'm
pretty sure you know the other one I'd
be surprised if you do but we'll see
number two Clara Oswald in death in
heaven so this is the only other Clara
one I'm counting I am not counting the
earlier version so we're not counting
Oswin from an asylum of the Daleks we're
not counting the governess from the
snowmen nor am i counting last Christmas
because even though that was originally
written with the intention that it would
be her final episode it was also really
written when Jenna Coleman decided she
wasn't going to leave so the episode as
aired is not setting her up to leave
anymore even though you can see how it
was supposed to go but this death in
heaven was written originally to be
Clara's exit from the show and it still
functions as that and it could have been
that and there's no reason why it
couldn't have been her last episode and
there's something about that last
conversation between the doctor and
Clara where they lie to each other about
their own pain maybe out of selfishness
maybe out of an effort to save the other
one any more pain than they know they're
already in and sort of feeling like they
each probably know that the other one's
lying but they're gonna let the lie
stand because sometimes that's how
relationships friendships end not by
tragic circumstances not by mutual
agreement sometimes just by something's
broken and it's just not what it was and
we can't even really talk about it and I
felt like this captured that really
really well and I really really wish
that either this or face the Raven was
the closeout of Clara story because I
think this is so much better not only
better than the exit she got had it been
truly her exit I'm still having it
because it was designed to be and had
this stood as her exit it's one of the
great ones it really is I feel there's a
severe under appreciate
for these closing scenes of death in
heaven but even if it was her last
appearance it still wouldn't get the
number one spot because number one spot
could not possibly go to anybody other
than Donna Noble in journey's end you
want to talk about tragedy there is
nothing as heartbreaking as Donna
shaking her head going no no please as
the doctor comes up to erase her mind
because he want to compare it to the
other tragedies you want to compare it
to
Rose rose absolutely sold the pain of
being on the other side of that wall but
she still got to remember what there was
and what happened was circumstance that
they thought they had a handle on it but
they didn't and there is a tragedy to
that but it's not quite the same or the
tragedy of Amy making the choice of how
the rest of her life was gonna go in
that it was gonna be without the doctor
there's a tragedy that she had to make
that choice but she still got to make it
donna has her choice taken from her and
not by circumstance but by her best
friend by the person that she would
rather die than forget that person takes
from her the choice and it was choice
that she made very clear what she would
rather do that she would rather die than
forget and he won't let her and how sad
she is and how much it breaks the
doctors heart to do it and how broken
Wilf looks
when the doctor shows up Madonna and
Wilfred just melts this is tragedy as
Beauty this breaks my heart every time
it hurts but it hurts in a way that
makes you feel alive and that is why
Donna Noble journey's end best companion
exit of modern Doctor Who that's my list
that's my ranking you want to fight me
on what even qualifies to be on here
what stuff should I have included that I
didn't know what's on here that
shouldn't be on here
how should I have reordered them however
you want to yell at me for this list
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do as well because there's buttons
and links and there's the patreon down
there which super helpful and you know
there's rewards and everything and get
your name in the credits amongst other
stuff plus you know a whole bunch of
other stuff links to my social merch
click on stuff or don't you don't have
to at the end of the day folks you are
the council
I'm just running the meetings until next
time this council mr. jerk
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]